did you charm your way into a superstars
broadway like their their dressing room
one time when you were ten oh yes i was
ten years old
look this is bold for ten i was bold so
let's bold for thirty you don't get to
you know why I am in bold irrespective
soon so I'm ten years old want to be a
child actor I'm living in Dayton Ohio
there's nothing happening
it's the mid second and I see Liza
Minelli's luggage says Liza Minnelli in
a stencil and this is like cabaret time
she's like it this is like her door
height and I go to the front desk oh
what room is Liza Minnelli and they told
me what did you pretend like you're her
family I just don't know what I did I
just flat out asked and I went up
knocked on the door in the middle of the
day and she answered in a bathrobe
what did you say hi I'm Rob Lowe and I
want to be an actor oh my god she was
awesome she invited me into the room she
was there with her then-husband who is
the Tin Man son from Wizard of Oz Jack
Jack Haley jr. yeah and they were I now
realize from an adult perspective what
they were probably up to considering was
the middle of the day and they were in
robes and eating chocolate and drinking
red wine
they were so nice to me and Liza was
fascinated and wanted to know why I
wanted to be an actor was awesome so
cool then you fast forward to 35 years
later I'm sitting in the front row at
the Hollywood Bowl what lies is
performing and now we're friends and
like I've had a big what a fantastic
first time for a kid their experience
that's amazing now she's the best was I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this